Đóng đoàn đến lực Việt Nam cho biết, mang quan lý dự án định một và các đơn vị linh quan vừa hạn đặt thành công bánh xe công tác tổ máy số một tại công chính nhà máy thuy định hoa bình bởi giọc.
Một cuộc móc kỹ thuật quan trọng trong quá trình thí công lắp đặt thiết định.
Bánh xe công tác, thiết bị xưa trọng lượng 1 trong mùi tấn, được nüp khẩu tư nước ngoài, được nhà thấu lý là ma trực tiếp thử viện hạn đặt.
Qua trình thí công đoài hỏi sự phối hợp chất chế, chính sáp để đối vào đam ăn toàn giữa các bên linh quan.
Theo ban khỏe lý dự án định một việc hòa thành hạn đặt bánh xe công tác tạo điều kiện trình hai các hạn một thiết bị tiếp theo như nắp hẩn tu bình, chục tu bình, vành điều khiến ổ hướng tu bình.
Nhằm tiến tới tổ hợp xưa tổ máy số một trong thằng sau năm 2020.
Các bên đăng cưới lịch bám sát tiến độ, phần đầu đưa tổ máy số một phát định trước ngày 12 thành chiến năm 2020,
khoan thành tổng bộ dự án trong năm 2020.
Nhà máy thiết định hoa bình mở dụng gồm hai tổ máy, tổng công sức 4 trăm tảm với mấy người gà quá,
khi vọc bộ dụng khoảng năm 2014, một năm cho hệ thống định Cúch gia,
gói phần tăng cường của định và hiệu quả phần hành tòàn hệ thống.